this video is sponsored by the great
courses plus
hoping to motivate shannon to move a bit
faster john got up from waiting at the
kitchen table
went outside and sat in the car there
was no particular time that they needed
to be at shannon's parents per se
but they had mutually decided on what
was now about 45 minutes ago
and john had been lingering in the sort
of antsy anticipatory mood while he
waited for shannon to be ready
he now sat in the car alternating
through different vr apps
exhausting all recently available short
form content and other relevant updates
that didn't require his full attention
or much time after about 10 more minutes
passed he went back inside to see what
was going on
he found shannon in the kitchen eating a
snack
are you serious john said what are you
doing let's go
i just needed a minute shannon replied
alright well are you good now
john said yeah shannon let out with a
ring of annoyed indifference
during the initial part of the car ride
jon acted pissy towards shannon
exhibiting some weird hybrid of both
passive and active aggressiveness
shannon knew he was frustrated about
running late and they briefly squabbled
back and forth over the seriousness of
it or lack thereof
after just a little while they mostly
calm down and reset
moving on to talk normally about a
series of different topics
sharing each other's lives with the
depth clarity and care
that only really comes with a genuine
deep connection
a little less than halfway through the
30 minute drive shannon opened her purse
and sifted through it looking for a
snack pill to hold her over until dinner
while she did john looked over into her
purse out of the corner of his eyes to
double check
that she had brought the portable ssd
memory display drive
that he gave her earlier to put in her
bag when he didn't see it right away
he said you did bring the memory drive
right
shannon paused abruptly looked up and
forward with a blank stare
and then quickly began sifting through
her purse again then
her jacket pockets the drive was for
shannon's father
john was an architect and interior
designer who used 3d animated vr
and ar software to create virtual models
of residential and retail property
designs
that could be experienced as virtual or
augmented realities within actual spaces
john promised shannon's father that he
would create some iterations for the new
house extension
and remodel that they were planning he
talked to him just a couple days prior
and said it was all set to show him
it was one of the main reasons why they
were going to visit
as it became increasingly apparent that
shannon probably didn't have it
john said with a clenched voice shannon
how do you not know if you have it or
not
after exhausting her performance shannon
said with an annoyed yet guilty
exasperation
i don't know can you just relax for a
second briefly closing her eyes and
drooping her head down
you seriously didn't bring it i handed
it right to you it's a simple thing
john said i know i must have put it on
the counter when you handed it to me and
forgot to put it in my bag after
it's called an accident she replied
neither were true john had actually put
it on the counter himself and then told
shannon that it was there
but never really explicitly asked her to
grab it which made it sort of both their
mistake
john exhaled with a long grunting sound
and the car went quiet for several
minute long seconds you know it's really
not that big of a deal
we can just go back and get it if you
want i don't mind and my parents will be
fine in another hour
shannon said we already left an hour
late to begin with shannon
john said then going on to insistently
argue with her
quickly turning the relatively mild
inconvenience into a more than mild one
[Music]
john truly loved shannon at this point
they had been married for 18 years
shannon's more carefreeness and looser
relationship with time was one of the
key qualities that deeply attracted him
to her
and likewise his rigid pragmatism
attracted her to him
however like many relationships this
uniting glue was simultaneously the
sticking point to many of their problems
the conflicting bond of two opposite
poles
consequently they loved each other with
the kind of love that doesn't always
look like love
but is nonetheless just as real as any
other this moment in the car however
was not unusual along with his rigid
pragmatic outlook
john learned this sort of outward
display of anger towards those you love
from his father and although he never
did including in this moment
think it was okay he unfortunately also
faultily learned alongside
that apparently sometimes you do things
that aren't okay
similarly as a child shannon had learned
to see it as normal as well
after turning around to go back for the
rest of the ride john and shannon didn't
really talk much
[Music]
at some point along the way john stopped
the car to get a battery boost at a
charging station
less than 15 minutes later they arrived
home went inside
and there on the table was the memory
drive john grabbed it with a sort of
apathetic looseness of the arm and gave
it to shannon
shannon placed it in her purse and the
two returned to the car
while getting in john noticed that the
charging port of the car was open
and the dust cover was missing he
immediately realized that he had
forgotten to put it back
on at the charging station john cursed
at the air and slammed the door of the
car open and close behind him as he got
in
he was mad at himself because it was
obviously his fault but he didn't avoid
the opportunity to state the absurd
notion that
if they hadn't had to turn around he
wouldn't have stopped at the station and
forgotten the cover
the cover was cheap and relatively
insignificant but the error upset john
enough to dip
him back into the state causing him to
say ridiculous stuff like this
putting both him and shannon in even
worse moods overall
about a half hour or so later john and
shannon were at her parents house
they put on their best happy faces and
had a nice conversation over dinner
they talked about all sorts of stuff and
fairly quickly john and shannon's fake
happy faces turned into real ones as
they discussed the variety of pleasant
and engaging topics related to their
shared life
at some point john mentioned to
shannon's father that he brought the
drive
he handed it to him reiterating what he
did on it and suggested that after
dinner they go through it together
her father thanked him sincerely and
agreed and then the conversation
continued on
only a few moments later shannon's
mother asked both of them if the company
john worked for
could possibly help with the final
execution of their renovation
shannon promptly said that jon had
already set up the plans and could get
them a substantial discount on it as
well
john discreetly and softly nudged
shannon's leg under the table without
looking at her
quickly speaking up and saying how he
still needed to get all the approvals
worked out first
but was hopeful that it should be fine
her parents were very happy to hear it
and said they understood if it didn't
work
either way the dinner wrapped up and at
least from shannon's parents perspective
was very nice on the drive home
john asked shannon why she answered the
question about his company
asking in a flippant way that was clear
he wasn't really looking for an answer
he knew it wasn't that big of a deal and
the approvals were almost certainly
going to be fine
but he still didn't want her parents to
know before he was sure
and he knew shannon knew that shannon
now rather exhausted from the day
said she obviously slipped and didn't
mean to john now also exhausted
kind of snapped back at her response
saying how he knew it was a mistake
but didn't understand how she could make
it they went back and forth for a little
while
each possessing less energy now than
earlier yet somehow arguing with more
intensity
at some point it became unnecessarily
personal and each said things that left
bruises on each other's minds
it didn't take long before they both
more or less non-verbally agreed that
they had said enough
the rest of the car ride was mostly
quiet
upon getting home the two continued to
mostly pout around and avoid each other
they watched some tv and then went to
bed without saying much more than a
couple words
each falling asleep with a sour taste in
their mouth both wanting to just turn
around and wash it out with apologies
and amends
but neither doing so
this is the 658th time jon has lived
this day
at least once every week he relives this
or one of the prior several days
through a memory retrieval software the
software works by using a brain-computer
interface
which scans the short and long-term
memory areas of the user's brain
retrieving mapping and reconstructing
their neural firings as the user
attempts to recall specific memories
simultaneously it scans and maps the
visual network part of the brain that is
activated in relation to the memories
conjoining the two sources of data and
forming it into a hyper
real film-like interpretational
rendering which can be saved like a
video and experienced as a pov
through vr and ar devices
this particular day this particular
memory
was the last one john had with shannon
the next morning on her walk to work
she was hit by a car and killed
this last day that he had with her and a
collection of some several other days
prior
are the only clear full days john could
properly retrieve
following the accident he occasionally
alternates across the different days
which are mostly all essentially the
same and sometimes watches just
individual moments that he was able to
recall as isolated memories
but something about this last full day
specifically feels the clearest and most
real
he loves re-experiencing it as if it
were his actual day
hearing shannon's voice seeing her face
and experiencing the illusion of being
there with her for the last time
every time however he has to watch
himself treat shannon with crassness
impatience and disregard over what is
now so
clearly nothing generally simple
insignificant blips of order and plans
almost always a mistake that was equal
part if not fully his own
almost always things with the
consequence of little to nothing
generally minor inconveniences turned
major generally good moments or days
turned bad for no real reasons
and every time it devastates him but
despite these days being filled with
mundane ordinariness
and these childish displays of useless
anger and frustration
they are better than almost all the days
john has had since
people often say live every day as if it
were your last
but far less commonly do you hear live
every day
as if it were everyone else's it isn't
easy for john
it's a constant effort the loss of his
wife didn't make the obvious but nearly
impossible cliches of life any easier
for a while it made even just showering
feel like a hike
but as a token to the lesson of her
memory john now tries with full
commitment
to consider in each and every
interaction he has with those he likes
loves or hates what if this were his
last one
what if yesterday's was or tomorrow's
will be
one never knows for sure which memory
will be their last with someone
until they can't form any anymore
and now every time john goes out into
the world with friends family or
strangers
he tries to remind himself and ask if
this were the last time
the memory that i would have to relive
over and over as the last one
would it hurt to watch more than it has
to
this video was sponsored by the great
courses plus
perhaps one of the hardest parts of
maintaining lifelong education
is finding the means to properly do so
without giving up too much of your time
and resources
the great courses plus is a curated
on-demand video learning
platform that provides a library of over
11 000 reliable
in-depth lectures taught by professors
from ivy leagues and top
universities around the world as well as
places like national geographic
making learning on your own terms
convenient organized and dependable
with content offered in areas like
science philosophy
psychology history linguistics math art
and much more
there are courses for just about
anyone's interests if you enjoy learning
about different topics related to human
behavior
and the reasons we do the strange things
we do one particularly great course is
entitled
understanding the mysteries of human
behavior taught by professor of
psychology and neuroscience mark leary
in which he goes into a wide array of
topics related to the evolutionary
origins of human behaviors
the formation and consequences of
certain personality traits
the causal interactions between our
social world and internal experiences
and so on a subscription to the great
courses plus can now easily be gifted
through their website
making a great gift for a curious mind
or of course you can start your own
subscription
and test out their free trial today by
visiting thegreatcoursesplus.com
pursuit of wonder or by clicking the
link in the description below
and of course thank you so much for
watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
you